The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
AMARTYA SHANKHA
BISWAS: Let's start.
So today we're going to do
some NP hardness reductions.
So let's just do a
quick recap of P and NP.
So let's see.
So P is-- so you have
a decision problem.
So I have an input x and
you have some algorithm, A,
and it spits out an answer,
which is either 0 or 1.
So that's a decision problem.
And if a problem isn't
P, this algorithm A
runs in polynomial time.
So what about NP?
So NP is when the solution is
verifiable in polynomial time.
So let's say you have an
input x and some oracle, which
is [INAUDIBLE] run
exponential time or is
has infinite computation
time gives you an answer,
so you get x and you get an
answer which is either 0 or 1.
And you also get a certificate.
So let's call that
a certificate.
And given these
three values, you
can verify whether the
solution was correct or not
in polynomial time.
Make sense?
So clearly if you're
going to compute
the answer in
polynomial time, you
can also verify in
polynomial time.
So P is a subset of NP.
And so that's it.
So now, NP hard
problems are problems
that are at least as hard to
solve as any problem in NP.
And so now today we're going
to be doing some reductions.
So I think we did
some of them in class,
Nintendo games or something.
Is that what we did?
So today we are going to do
some less interesting examples,
but let's see.
So how do we do reductions?
So if we know that
we have a problem A,
which is a hard
problem, and we want
to show that problem B is hard.
So we want to draw
this implication.
So if we want to draw
this implication--
so this is equivalent to
saying that if B is easy,
then A is easy.
Sorry, other way.
This is the counter positive.
So assuming that B has a
polynomial time solution,
A has a polynomial
time solution.
And that statement is equivalent
to saying if A is hard,
B is hard.
So if you know that A
is an NP hard problem,
we can say that B is
an NP hard problem.
So if we want to show that
B is an NP hard problem,
first we show that B
is an NP, and then we
show that B is hard.
So the way do this step is--
so your A looks like this.
You have your algorithm, and it
spits out an answer in 0 to 1.
And B looks like this.
Let's say you have an
input y and it spits out
an answer in 0 to 1.
And you want to find a
function R which takes your x
and sends it to y.
So basically, if you know how
to solve B very fast, then
you can take an input to A. So
you take x, you transform it,
and then you apply
B. And the condition
is that A applied to x is the
same as B applied to R of x.
So basically, what
you are doing is
you're showing that A is
easy by showing that you can
use-- so let's say B is easy.
We can use B to compute
A, so then A must be easy.
But since we know
that A is hard,
that there's something wrong in
our logic, so B must be hard.
Does that makes sense?
Yes?
Sort of?
So let's move onto
an actual problem.
So the first problem
we're going to reduce
is the Hamiltonian path.
So a well-known NP hard problem
is the Hamiltonian cycle.
So here our A is-- so
it's a Hamiltonian cycle.
So what's a Hamiltonian cycle?
So a Hamiltonian cycle-- so
let's say you have a graph.
So we have this graph.
Let me draw this out.
That's it.
So a Hamiltonian
cycle is a cycle
in the graph which
starts at some vertex,
visits all the other
vertices, and comes back
to the starting vertex.
So in this case, we could
do something like go here,
and then take this vertex, take
this vertex, take this vertex,
and come back here.
So that is a valid
Hamiltonian cycle.
So this graph is a
So the decision problem is
here that given the graph,
does it have a
Hamiltonian cycle?
And that problem is NP-hard,
so you can [INAUDIBLE]
polynomial [INAUDIBLE].
So now the new
polynomial shows NP-hard,
which is B is Hamiltonian path.
So the Hamiltonian path
is a very similar problem.
Instead of a cycle, you
remove the requirement
that you have to come back
to the starting point.
You can just start anywhere and
[INAUDIBLE] all the vertices
and stop.
So for example, if
you remove this edge,
this graph no longer
has Hamiltonian cycle,
but it has a Hamiltonian
path, which is just this line.
Simple.
So this is a simple reduction
because the problems
are very similar.
So the first step is,
of course, showing
that Hamiltonian path is an NP.
So that should be pretty
clear because-- so what is
our certificate here?
So if someone says, OK, I have
solved the Hamiltonian path
and this is my Hamiltonian path.
And he gives you a certificate
which is the actual path.
So you can always look at the
certificate, check the path,
and see if it's a valid path.
And then you can verify the
answer in polynomial time.
So that's the linear
time verification.
So this is true.
So now what we're going
to show is B is hard.
So the way we do that
is we do a reduction.
So the reduction is given an
input to the original problem,
A. So let's say an input to
A is in the form of a graph.
And now you have transformed
this graph somehow to G dash.
And then you have to
argue that-- so this
is the transformation
R-- and you
have to argue that the
solution, the answer that this
will spit out, is the
same amount that this
would spit out.
So let's look at the
transformation first.
Anyone have any ideas?
So you have a graph
and you're using
that to solve the
Hamiltonian cycle problem.
So how do you
transform it in a way
that lets you cast into
Hamiltonian path formulation?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Remove an edge?
AMARTYA SHANKHA
BISWAS: Not exactly.
So which edge would you remove?
You can't find the
Hamiltonian cycle.
OK, important point.
So there's no point
doing this reduction
unless this reduction
is itself polynomial
because otherwise,
this whole strategy
of transforming and then using
B to find A doesn't work.
Because if the reduction
is exponential time,
that doesn't help you.
So it--
AUDIENCE: Try
removing every edge.
AMARTYA SHANKHA BISWAS: So
if you remove some edges,
you'll see that there is
still a Hamiltonian cycle.
But you remove some
edges-- you can't tell.
You don't know which
edge to remove.
So a better way
to do it is this.
So let's say this is
the rest of your graph.
And you just look at one vertex.
So look at one vertex,
V. And let's say
this is a directed graph.
If it's an undirected
graph, you can just
like add one edge there and
one edge back for everything.
So now you add a
directed edge along this.
I'm sorry.
You look at all
the directed edges.
So let's say you have
some edges coming in
and you have some
edges going out.
So this is just a
vertex and you just
look at the rest of
the graph and look
at all the edges coming in
and all the edges going out.
So this is in A. This
is the original problem.
And you transform this into--
you split the vertex into two,
so V dash and V
double-dash, let's say.
And in one of them, you
keep all the incoming edges
and the other one contains
all the outgoing edges.
Does that transformation
make sense intuitively?
So what do you have here?
So here you had-- let's say this
graph had a Hamiltonian cycle.
So this graph had
some cycle which
went up here, did something,
something, and came back.
So it would go like this.
It would do the
cycle and come back.
So there was some cycle.
And since the cycle, it contains
V, so now what you're doing
is you're splitting apart
V and disconnecting them.
So you'll still have-- if you
look at the original path,
it's still there, but it's
been split up into a path now.
It's no longer a cycle.
Make sense?
So now let's argue
this more rigorously.
So what we want to say
here is that let's say
there was a cycle here.
If there was a cycle
here, then is it clear
that there is a path here?
Because just take the same
edges that you had before.
If you take the same
edges, they will now
form a path instead of a cycle.
So cycle implies path.
Does that makes sense?
So the other way is
a little more tricky.
So let's say you have a path.
So let's say you had a path.
So that means that-- let's
redraw this so it's more clear.
So you have this new graph where
you have two vertices, V dash
and V double-dash.
This has a bunch
of incoming edges
and this is a bunch
of outgoing edges.
So now let's say you have a
Hamiltonian path in this graph.
So what does that mean?
So where can the
Hamiltonian path start?
Can it start anywhere?
Where can it start?
AUDIENCE: V double-dash.
AMARTYA SHANKHA BISWAS: Right,
because V double point doesn't
have any incoming
edges, so it can't
be in the middle of the path.
So it has a start here.
So it starts.
It does something in there.
And where can it end?
It can only end,
similarly, in V dash.
Because V dash doesn't
have any outgoing edges,
so it can't be in the
middle of the path.
So it has to end in V dash.
So now, if you have
a path like that,
and you go back to this graph--
so V dash and V double-dash
are now on the same vertex.
And just that path just
becomes a cycle now.
So path implies cycle.
So now what we have is
previously what we had, right?
So now we know that A of G
here is equal to B of G dash.
So G dash was transformation.
Also notice that the
transformation was just
splitting apart a vertex.
So depending on your
representation of your graph,
it'll take something, like
constant time or linear time
or something
polynomial, essentially.
So you get a
polynomial-time reduction.
After reduction, you
show that the answer
to the reduced problem
is the same as the answer
to the original problem.
And that means that this
is also an NP-hard problem
by the argument given here.
Questions?
Does that make sense?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So are you
creating two vertices
for every vertex in the graph?
AMARTYA SHANKHA BISWAS:
No, just this one.
Just pick any vertex--
doesn't matter--
because you have a cycle.
So if you take any vertex and
split it apart, you get a path.
AUDIENCE: Oh, perfect.
AMARTYA SHANKHA
BISWAS: Anything else?
OK, let's move on
to the next one.
Grab a new board.
So the next problem
is-- so given the graph,
is there a k-clique?
Do people know what a clique is?
So a clique is this.
So a clique is a
set of vertices.
So let's say C subset of
V for the set of vertices,
such that C is a complete graph.
Let's just draw a diagonal.
That's probably easier.
OK.
So in this example, so
you have this graph.
This one.
So look at this set of vertices.
Every pair of them is
connected to each other.
What that means is
that if you just
look at the graph
with these vertices,
it's a complete graph.
That's what's called a clique.
And in this case,
this is a 4-clique.
So you have four vertices,
So the position problem
is, given the graph,
does there exist a k-clique?
So this is, again, known
to be an NP-hard problem.
So now we will use this to show
that this problem is NP-hard.
So this problem is
independent set.
So again, so given the graph,
what is an independent set?
Anyone want to explain?
So what an independent
set is this.
So let's say you
have a graph which
looks like-- so kind
of complementary
to the definition of a clique.
An independent set
is a set of vertices,
such that no pair of them
has an edge between them.
So in this case, if
you took this vertex,
you took this vertex, this
vertex, and this vertex--
so you can see, none
of these vertices
have an edge between them, so
that is an independent set.
So in this case, you're
taking a set of vertices
which is a complete
graph, so all of them
have edges between them.
And in this case, you're taking
vertices which are completely
disconnected.
So now we're going to find a
reduction from this problem
to this problem.
So first of all,
independent set is an NP.
Is that clear?
How would you show that?
So how would you create
a certificate which
would tell you that--
so how would someone
create a certificate
which would convince you,
in polynomial-time,
that this is correct?
So the certificate would be just
give you the independent set.
And you can check if
something is independent set.
So given I-- let's call the
independent set, I. So given
the set of vertices,
you can verify
that it is an independent
set in polynomial-time.
So just look at
all pairs and check
if there's an edge--
just an n squared
and Q whatever is polynomial.
That's important.
So now let's look at
our transformation.
So again, as before, you have
A, which is given by a graph,
and you want to
transform into something.
So the important note here
is that in the clique,
you have-- so for your clique
C, all the pairs of vertices
are connected.
In I, no pair of
vertices are connected.
So what should be a logical
transformation that would map
a clique to an independent set?
Anyone?
What do you think you
should do to the graph
so that the clique
becomes-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: Invert the
existence of edges
so they're [INAUDIBLE].
AMARTYA SHANKHA
BISWAS: Precisely.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AMARTYA SHANKHA BISWAS: Yup.
Exactly.
Great.
So all you have to
do is if you want
to turn a clique into
independent set, you
just-- what is it-- complement
the adjacency matrix.
So every edge does not exist
now exists and every edge that
did exist is gone.
So you create a graph, G dash,
with the same [INAUDIBLE]
vertices, except the edges
are now complemented.
So the E bar just means
the edges that were not.
So let's just draw an example.
So let's say you had--
and what does this become?
So let's draw the
vertices first.
Let's go one by one.
So let's take this vertex.
Let's take this vertex.
And what edges does it have?
So it goes here.
It goes here.
It doesn't go here, so
we draw an edge here.
It doesn't go there, so we
draw another edge there.
And it doesn't go there, so
we draw another edge there.
Now, this vertex.
It's connected to all of
these except this one.
So that means that
there's an edge there.
Let's take this vertex.
It's connected to everything.
Oh, it's connected
to everything.
Let's take this one.
It's connected to these
two and nothing else,
so we need to connect
it to this guy.
And I think that's it.
Yeah.
Similarly proceeding,
this is connected
to everything except that,
so I guess this goes there.
And I think that's it, right?
Or is there more?
Three.
No, OK.
So that is a complementary
graph I think.
So you can probably verify that.
So now let's look at the
clique in this graph.
So this is the clique.
This is the largest clique,
rather, but this is a clique.
You could have other
cliques, like, for example,
this these three things
are also a clique.
So now look at what
this is mapping to.
This is mapping to this vertex,
this vertex, this vertex,
and this vertex.
And you can see that's
an independent set.
So does that
transformation make sense?
So now the proof should
be intuitively clear.
So let's just go through
it moderately rigorously.
So let's say you
have a clique here.
So your clique here, for every
pair of vertices in the clique,
there's an edge between them.
And so if that maps to--
so let's say clique C maps
to-- let's say this maps to I.
So for all U, V element of C,
you have U, V, element
of E. So if this
is a clique, for every
pair of vertices,
that edge is in the
original graph, which
means that U, V is not an
element of E for all U, V
element of I.
So for every U, V
element of I, we
have this, which means
that-- does that make sense?
So that means that that's the
independent set criterion.
So you reduced clique
to independent set.
And that means that
independent set is now NP-hard.
OK.
How are we doing on time?
So now let's do a more
complicated example.
Any questions on these two?
Make sense?
OK.
So let's try this.
So let's start by
erasing something.
So this is the next problem.
So as before, our A is k-clique.
So it says there's
a clique-- rather,
let's add this in this way.
Clique size greater
than or equal to k.
So that's the decision problem.
Is there a clique of size
greater than or equal to k?
And B is, it's called Max-2-SAT.
So what that means is
that-- so it is somewhat
like normal 2-SAT, except
basically you have some clauses
and you have some literals.
So each of these literals
contain values 1 or 0.
And each of these clauses
is something like xi or xj.
And actually, there can be
naughts in front of this,
so let's say xi 0 xj.
Or it can be other things.
So it's xi 0 xj,
or 0 xi 0 xj, or xi
xj, and so on and so forth,
so just the normal 2-SAT.
So now the decision
problem is to-- does
there exist an assignment, such
that greater than equal to k
clauses-- so that
the decision problem.
So is there an assignment to
literals such that at least k
of these clauses are satisfied?
And so now we're going to
show that it is with k-clique.
So again, is it an NP?
So what is the certificate?
How would someone convince you
their solution to this problem?
AUDIENCE: Give you the literals.
AMARTYA SHANKHA BISWAS: Yeah,
so give you an assignment
of values to literals.
And then you can go through
all the clauses and check them.
So if they give you like x1
equal to 1, x2 equal to 2,
x equal to 0, x3 equal to
1, and so on and so forth,
you can then go through
and check all the clauses
and see if greater
than k are satisfied.
So this is an NP.
So now let's try the reduction.
So this is how the
reduction goes.
Let's see.
So naturally, we have
k-clique, or greater
than equal to k-clique, rather.
So that means you have a
graph with a set of vertices
and a set of edges.
So let's say you have a
clique, V dash, subset of V,
and mod of V dash is
greater than equal to k.
So now you have to
somehow construct
literals, construct
clauses, which
will reflect this behavior.
So first of all, this may
not be clear right now,
but let's say we take
some literals like this.
So let's say we take xi
for all i element of V.
So for every vertex in the
graph, we take a literal.
So if the number
of vertices is n,
we have n literals because it's
corresponding to each vertex.
Also, we take a dummy literal.
Let's call it Z.
So now how do we
get our clauses?
So the general idea is that
if a vertex is in the clique,
you will assign it 1.
If it's not in the clique,
we will assign it 0.
Everything outside
of the clique is 0.
So this clause,
not xi or not xj--
so what is the value of
this clause normally?
So let's say xi and xj are
both outside the clique.
So i and j are both
outside the clique.
That means that both of them
are 0 and so this is true.
What if one of them is inside
the clique and the other one
is outside?
It still is true because
one of these naughts is 1
and that is still true.
Let's say both i and j
are inside the clique.
So in that case, you have 0 of
xi is 0 and 0 of xj is also 0.
That's the only case
that this is false.
So the way we take
care of-- so we're
trying to maximize the number
of true clauses in some sense.
It's like you had maybe
an explanation of why
you're using this clause.
So what we do instead of
taking all the xi, xj pairs,
is we just take xi,
xj, such that i,
j is not an element of E.
So what does that mean?
So now if you had the graph
which looked like this, now
it looks like 1, 2, 3, 4.
So you would take 0 x1 and 0 x4.
You would take 0 x1 and 0 x3.
But you would not
take 0 x2 and 0 x3.
So what does that do?
That means that if you follow
the assignment according
to the clique rules-- so if i
and j are both in the clique,
this clause will
not be included.
Does that make sense-- what
set of clauses you are taking?
OK, so let's continue
and it will hopefully
be a little more clear.
So the other sort of clause
we're going to take is xi or z.
And the other one is xi or 0 z.
So the reason we're
taking these is
that if you wanted to
Max-2-SAT on this alone,
you can just set
everything to 0,
and that would
give you a maximum.
So sort of not do that--
so to sort of minimize
the number of things to be
set to 0, you were doing this.
So is this just some hand-wavy
argument why you're doing this.
So let's actually try to
do some analysis on this.
So let's say you do
this transformation.
So do the clauses make sense?
Does the first clause sense?
So you have 0 xi, 0 xj for every
i, j which is not in the graph.
So how does this work?
So let's say you have V dash
such that size of V dash
is greater than or equal to k.
Actually, let's just make
size is V dash equal to k.
So if you have a clique of size
greater than or equal to k,
of course, you have a
clique of size equal to k.
You can just throw away
some of the vertices.
So you take your V dash such
that this size is equal to k.
And you set xi is equal to 1.
So you set xi equal to 1 if
i is element of V dash 0,
if i is not an
element of V dash.
Make sense?
So you would set everything in
your clique to be 1, everything
outside to be 0.
And let z equal to 1.
So you're starting
with the assumption
that-- so you're
showing one direction.
You're showing that given
that there's a clique of size
greater than equal to k.
And now you're are going
to construct a Max-2-SAT
instance which has the satisfied
number of clauses greater
than equal to k.
And then we'd show
the other direction.
So now let's look
at how many clauses
we have to be satisfied.
So the first type of clause
was 0 of xi or 0 of xj.
So how many of these
clauses are being satisfied?
So first case, i and G
are both outside V dash.
Is the clause
satisfied in that case?
Yes, because by definition,
if they're outside V dash,
they're both 0, so their naughts
are both 1, so they're 1.
So if the i and j are
outside V dash, you're good.
So what about the case when
one of them is inside V dash?
Is the clause satisfied.
Yeah, because one of them
is 0, which makes the 0 1,
and the whole thing is.
It's an [? arc, ?]
so it's satisfied.
Let's say both of them
are inside V dash.
Let's say both i and
j are inside V dash.
Then this clause just doesn't
exist because of the condition
that i, j had 0 elements
of V. Because if it's
inside the clique, then
that edge obviously
exists, and therefore
this clause is not
in the set of
clauses we're using.
So essentially, every clause
of this form will be satisfied.
And how many clauses
of this form are there?
The number of
clauses of this form
is just E bar, where E
is the complementary edge
set of that graph.
That's E bar.
Does that make sense?
Next clause is xi or z.
So since we have
considered z to be 1,
this clause is always satisfied.
So this just gives us
mod of V because this
is for every i-- I
should mention that.
For i, this is also for all i.
So for every i, so they all
have a number of xi's are
V, so that's it.
So the third type of clause
is xi or 0 of v. So 0 of z,
since z is 1, 0 of x is 0.
So the only cases where this
clause is true is where?
Is when xi is 1.
And xi is one only
inside V dash,
so the number of
clauses satisfied here
is mod of V dash.
And mod of V dash is what?
It's just k.
You see this?
All three clauses make sense?
Can you see why the first one
is it's the size of V bar?
Because all the
clauses are satisfied.
The second one,
also all the clauses
are satisfied because z is 1.
Every clause is just
the number of vertices.
And the last one, it's only
satisfied for the cases
where xi is 1.
And xi is 1 only
inside the clique,
so that gives you the
k things in the clique.
So now we can finish
formulating our transformation.
So our transformation
was you set--
where was the transformation?
Yes.
So these are our clauses and
now we're going to set the k.
So the Max-2-SAT was
with the condition of k.
So here you'll set it to be mod
of V bar plus mod of V plus k.
So does that make sense?
So basically, our Max-2-SAT
problem-- so the reduction
to the Max-2-SAT problem--
so we specified the clauses.
We specified the literals.
Literals were xi for
all iV and the dummy z.
We satisfied the clauses and
we specified the threshold
we are trying to achieve.
So those three things completely
specify the Max-2-SAT problem.
OK, proceeding.
So we just showed one direction.
We showed that if
there's a clique of size
greater than or equal
to k, we reduce this
to a size of exactly k.
Then we did this
assignment and we
showed that the total number
of clauses being satisfied
is mod of V bar plus
mod of V plus k.
And that is the first direction.
So now we're showing that--
so if you have a solution
to clique, we have a
solution to k-SAT, Max-k-SAT.
So now we do the
other direction.
So let's say we have a
solution to Max-k-SAT.
Let me get this out of the way.
Let's do this.
So let's say-- so this part
is a little more tricky.
So we start with Max-k-SAT has
a number of satisfied clauses
which is greater than or equal
to mod of V bar plus V plus k.
So we know that
max-SAT that accepts.
So know that so we define.
We define a V dash.
This V dash is in
the graph for clique
as the set of vertices i, such
that x of i is equal to 1.
So if our Max-k-SAT
has that many things,
then there's some assignment
to xi which satisfies that.
And we take that assignment.
And for every
value that is 1, we
put that in a-- it's
not a clique yet,
but it's, well, it's a
clique under construction.
So we make this clique
under construction
and we assign it values
of all the vertices
which are currently
labeled by 1.
But we don't know that
it's a clique, right?
It could not be a clique.
It could be something
like, let's say,
so this is the current V dash.
So V dash could be
something like you
have all these vertices
and let's say some of them
are connected.
But then you have this dangling.
So this is not connected.
This is not connected.
So it's not a clique.
So let's say this is vertex
i and this is vertex j,
and this whole thing is V dash.
And let's say somehow
you have this anomaly.
You have that this guy is not
connected to all the vertices.
So let's take one such pair.
And let's just say we remove xi.
So we just take the xi
and remove it from V dash.
What that equates to in the
Max-k-SAT is setting xi to 0.
So we take the original
satisfying assignment
and change the value of xi.
So let's see what that does.
So we take and
set xi equal to 0.
And xi was originally 1.
Let's actually write it down.
So xi, or rather, i, j
is not an element of E,
but-- so these i, j were in
the supposed to be clique,
but the i, j is not
in the edge set,
so it's not actually a clique.
So the way we resolve
that is just we do this.
We say, OK.
Let's just forget
about this vertex.
Let's say it's just
not in the clique.
So we set our xi to 0.
And what does that do?
Let's look at how that affects
the number of sat clauses.
So the first one
is x [? over ?] z.
So now here we had
not set z to be 1.
This is something in thing.
If z is equal to 0, we can
just replace z by 0 of z.
So the clauses are
symmetrical with respect to z.
So it's xi [? over ?]
z or xi 0 z.
So it doesn't matter which
one is set to be 1 or 0.
If one of them is
1, one of them is 0.
So let's just say that z is
1 without loss of generality.
So what that does is-- so
initially, this clause was 1
because z is 1.
And now it goes to 1
and nothing changes.
OK, sounds good.
What about the next one?
So now we have xi or 0 of z.
So 0 of z is 0 and xi just
went from being 1 to being 0.
So what happens here is that
initially, the clause value
was 1 and now it goes to 0.
So that's not good
because now we
are no longer satisfying
Max-k-sat clause possibly
because we had some number
of satisfying clauses,
which was above our threshold.
But now we lose a
clause and we could
be going below the threshold.
But then we look at
the third clause.
And what that does
is-- so let's say
we look at this specific
clause, the one which
said that xi and xj.
Note that this clause
exists because xi,
xj is not an edge you need.
And therefore, by
that condition,
this clause exists in
the set of clauses.
So what was the value of
this clause initially before?
In the initial assignment, what
was the value of this clause?
Note that i and j
are both in V dash.
What was the value
of this clause
in the original assignment?
Before we set xi to 0?
What was the value of xi
in the original assignment?
AUDIENCE: 1.
AMARTYA SHANKHA BISWAS:
Yes, why is it 1?
AUDIENCE: Because
xi was in V dash.
AMARTYA SHANKHA BISWAS: Yeah,
so xi was in V dash, so it's 1.
xj was also in V
dash because that's
the anomaly we saw it, right?
There was not an
edge in the clique.
So this was originally so
this was 1 and this was 1.
So this was 9 and this was 0.
And our R0, R0 is--
this used to be 0.
So what happens now though?
Does it change?
It changes to 1
because xi goes to 0.
Now this thing becomes 1
and so it changed to 1.
So there will be
other clauses with xi,
but realize that 0 of xi-- so
if xi is changed to 0, 0 of xi
is changing to 1.
So whatever happens
here, it will only
increase the number of clauses
that are being satisfied.
So you lose only 1, but
you gain at least 1.
So eventually, it
does not change.
It does not change the
number of satisfied clauses,
so that's important.
So what we did is we started
with some satisfying assignment
that we assumed existed.
And then we just
changed the variable
and we said that it's still
at least as many clauses
being satisfied.
So we did that.
And now we have one
less vertex that
is violating-- so now we
have one less vertex that is
violating the clique property.
So now we can take this
step-- this setting xi to 0.
We can just repeat this.
So how long do we repeat this?
So we repeat this till there
are no longer any violations.
So every time we find a
violation-- so once we delete
xi-- so let's this is gone.
So now we look for
the next violation.
The next violation is this edge.
So there's no edge there.
So we can either take this
vertex-- so let's call this k.
So we can either
remove xk or remove xj.
So we remove one of them.
And once you remove that, you
will end up with the 3-clique.
So what happens
is once we repeat
this, until V dash is a clique.
Does that make sense
why you can do that?
So you just keep
deleting vertices
until this is a clique.
And those clauses plus clause
condition is still satisfied.
You will still have greater than
or equal to that many clauses.
So now let's look
at what we have.
We have V dash, which is a
clique and xi is equal to-- so
once you have done this
process as many times
as you need, when
is xi equal to 1?
So remember that-- so V
dash is also being updated.
Every time you set xi to 0, xi
is being removed form V dash.
So that property is
always satisfied--
that define V dash equal
to xi for xi equal to 1.
That property's
always invariant.
That means that even after
reviewing these repetitions,
you still have xi equal
to 1, if and only if i
is E V dash and 0 otherwise.
So does make sense why
that property is solved?
So you have a clique and
you have this assignment.
So that should take
you back to this.
So remember where we
took a clique of size k
and we found that if you
go through all the algebra,
you will find something which
is like you will go through
and you will get mod of E bar
plus mod of V plus mod of k,
right?
So here you have a clique.
So forget about
what you did before.
So just consider
this is an assignment
according to those rules.
And those rules
give you that you
should get number
of satisfied clauses
is equal to mod of E bar plus
mod of V plus mod of V dash.
Realize that V
dash here is not k.
Does that make sense?
Because V dash is just-- so
you started with some set.
You started deleting
some elements.
You throw [INAUDIBLE]
randomly, but you ended up
with some V dash.
And by this argument,
you had E bar plus mod
of V plus mod of V dash--
E bar from this clause,
V from this clause, V
dash from this clause.
So you didn't end up with this.
And you know that because
of what we showed here
does not change number
of satisfied clauses,
it's still greater
than or equal to mod
of E bar plus mod of V plus k.
And we cancel this.
You cancel this.
And you get mod of V dash is
greater than or equal to k,
which means that you have
a clique of size greater
than equal to k.
Questions?
Does that make sense?
Really?
All of it?
OK.
That's good.
Any case.
So let's go back and see
what we are doing here.
So the way you are doing
NP-hard reductions is
you take a problem that
you already know is hard,
you take any arbitrary
instance of that problem,
and you transform the input
into an input to the problem
that you're trying
to show is hard.
So you take problem A,
which you know is hard.
You transform the input
into an input for problem B.
And then you show that if you
can solve [INAUDIBLE] problem
B, you will be able
to solve problem A.
But since you know you
can't solve problem
A in polynomial-time, you
know that you can't solve
problem B in polynomial-time.
And the other important
thing to notice
here is that the reduction
needs to polynomial-time.
So look at this
reduction, for instance.
What are you doing here?
You're taking every vertex.
You're making a clause.
And how many
clauses do you have?
Well, you have about n
squared clauses here.
You have Rn clauses and
you have Rn clauses here.
So time to construct that
is like roughly Rn squared.
So you're constructing the
clause in polynomial-time.
So you have a
polynomial-time reduction.
And if you reduce a
known NP-hard problem
in polynomial-time to
an unknown problem,
you can show that it is NP-hard.
OK.
I don't think we have time to do
another problem, so we're done.